89 it was a disastrous start for Denver
who had four turnovers in the first two
and a half minutes of this game 10 in
the first quarter after just eight in
all of game four and you were wondering
if maybe this was going to be a game two
type performance from them in terms of
the focus that Michael Malone has talked
about Denver came out a little tight
offensively and they were turning the
ball over but give him credit they
didn't let their bad offense make them
fall asleep defensively there are some
teams that when they're not doing it
defensively they have that woe is me
attitude there put their head down and
they start giving up shots even when the
shots weren't falling even when they
were turning it over you would see a
great hustle back by guys like
contavious Caldwell pole uh to get in on
those plays on some of those turnovers
so they weren't playing at a high
efficiency level early on but the hustle